[Music]
evolution usually takes thousands of
years but you might see some changes as
soon as 2050 with impressive new
technologies and constant changes men
and women won't be the same in the near
future or not even completely human did
you know that cyborgs already exist
watch a video to learn more about them
make sure you like this video and if it
is your first time visiting our channel
don't forget to subscribe today we are
showing you what humans will look like
by 2050 the beauty of colors interracial
relationships are becoming more and more
accepted in America as people realize
that love is colorblind with 15% of new
marriages between people of different
races we can see multiracial babies
being born every day humans are not only
white black or Asian soon we will also
be black eni's filipino chicken ease or
quarantine Ian you can already see many
good-looking multiracial men and women
in the United States and there will be
much more in the following years since
2000 the Census Bureau lets us check
more than one race at the same time and
6.8 million people did so then 10 years
after 9 million Americans identified
themselves as multiracial it represents
1/3 of the population
some of your friends are probably part
of them and that's what makes them so
beautiful next time you ask someone
where they are from their response might
be much more complicated and that's what
makes it so interesting this won't be
the story of one race but the story of
humanity with so much diversity we will
become one giant amalgamated mega race
in which everyone will be different and
equal this will completely redefine how
we imagine racial identities could it be
the end of discrimination based on race
oh we hope so the real Gattaca if you
have seen the science fiction movie
Gattaca you had a glimpse of what the
future could become soon in the film
parents can select their best genes to
make sure their children will be healthy
and live for a long time they can even
choose what they will look like what was
one chance out of a million became a
simple choice in Gattaca this leads to a
new generation of perfect human beings
this future is not far from us as the
technology needed to do this already
exist it is now possible to create
little humans with in vitro
fertilization and sperm donors parents
can choose some of their children's
character
mystics so it suits their preferences
with this new technology humans will be
more healthy handsome and strong in 2050
however some parents are not looking for
perfection but for something different
two deaf mothers asked for the help of a
sperm donor to make sure their child
would be deaf too they argued that it
was not a defect but an identity and a
culture what do you think of selecting
your children's genes do you think it is
a good idea tell us in the comments down
below the extinction of redheads by 2050
you should see fewer people with red
hair it takes only one red haired parent
to give birth to a ginger headed baby
but your redheads have a baby together
which decreases the chance of having a
baby with that hair color right now less
than 2% of the world's population has
red hair and there will be less in the
following years but should we really try
to protect the redheads from extinction
the natural red hair was created by a
mutation in Northern Europe thousands of
years ago at first the body of gingers
produce more vitamin D from sunlight
which was beneficial but now they are
only more prone to skin cancer and are
more sensitive to temperature it's the
end of redheads simply positive for
human evolution some scientists think
there will be no redheads as early as
2016 others think that the gene is
dormant and will come back later but if
you want to save the redheads there is
one thing you could do move to Scotland
it is estimated that 40% of Scottish
carry the red gene so if you have red
hair you might like to join them there
the end of evolution even though we
expect humans to evolve just like they
did before some scientists think they
won't will be the same in 2050 and in
thousands of years two evolutionary
changes usually happen in isolated
populations so human and animals can
adapt to their unique habitat a genetic
mutation is passed down through
generations because of its benefits to
help the species survive until it
becomes the norm this is what happened
in Galapagos with the animals that
Darwin studied but humans are not stuck
on an island they are part of a huge
community all around the world they also
have everything it takes to live
anywhere on the planet
as you can see Native Americans are the
same as Europeans even if it took
thousands of years for them to meet men
and women found another way to adapt to
their environment they use new
technologies instead of waiting for
evolution to happen
moreover not only the strongest human
survived we found out how to help the
weakest so they have the chance to live
- this means that everyone passed down
their genes not only those who are more
prone to survival we are going to learn
how to live with ourselves as we are but
aren't those imperfections what make
humans so beautiful the new body size
the more children you have the more
genes are passed to the next generation
the more humans will look like you
scientists found out that women who tend
to have more children are shorter and
stouter these two characteristics have a
high level of heritability so it is
easier for them to become part of
natural selection scientists also
predict that the children will have
lower cholesterol levels have lower
blood pressure tend to have their first
child earlier and reach menopause later
this will give them more chances to have
a lot of babies - so many humans will be
smaller and plumper by 2050 you might
have heard that men and women are taller
than they used to be before it is true
but for a different reason we are more
healthy and wealthy so we are now able
to reach our genetic potential in height
however humans maximum height will soon
become lower and lower even if we find a
way to live on Mars our body will use
more energy for maintenance than for
growth humans will only become shorter
no matter where we live don't feel bad
if you don't look like a tall and slim
top model being short and chubby is the
future of humanity the future of us what
will we look like in 2050 old life
expectancy was about 45 at the beginning
of the 20th century and it is about 80
today scientists suggest that with the
advancement of technology life
expectancy could increase to 120 as
early as 2050 that's almost the same age
than the oldest woman who ever existed
she was 122 years old at the time of her
death men and women will have fewer
children at an older age so they can
focus on something that is more
important for them instead of producing
children in quantity they will produce
children in quality our goal will be to
make sure our offspring are as
successful as possible because we will
have time to do so
we already dedicate more time to our
children than any other primate and it
will get more extreme over time humans
can't only give life to their offsprings
they also need to give them the
knowledge to live in our modern world
this is why parents of the future will
be Morpho
some cultural reproduction than
biological reproduction as scientists
said instead of living fast and dying
young
we will live slow and die old what would
you like to do if you could live up to
120 years old the power of the brain the
universal human ambition is to be more
intelligent we value this skill because
we can do anything we can imagine with
it we won't wait for natural selection
to give us this power as we will find a
way to be smarter with the use of
technology in 2013 scientists started
working on a way to choose the most
intelligent embryo out of ten with the
help of in vitro fertilization they
think this innovation could help parents
improve their child's IQ by eleven point
five and that could be even higher if
women accepted to undergo intensive
hormone treatments this means that in
ten generations the average IQ could be
115 points higher even though this
future is far from us it will be
possible to see a difference in 2050 if
we start using this new technology soon
there are about 10,000 genetic variants
associated with intelligence which makes
this kind of research intimidating but
some scientists are optimistic they
think we could be able to start
cognitive enhancement in the next ten
years this means that we might have the
chance to choose the IQ of our own kids
what the help of the best teachers the
children from the next generations could
become geniuses the loss of teeth don't
worry you won't be losing all your teeth
as it happens in a nightmare however
humans might not have wisdom teeth
anymore in the following years humans
used to have larger jaws thousands of
years ago because they ate things like
leaves roots and raw meat they also
needed teeth to replace those they lost
after they missed their appointment with
the dentist however we don't need wisdom
teeth anymore and there is not even
enough place for them in our mouths this
is why many people need to have their
third molars removed but some people's
teeth got the memo and never started to
grow wisdom teeth don't appear and 35%
of the population scientists think that
it means that wisdom teeth could
completely disappear in the following
years they aren't sure of the role DNA
plays in the development of these teeth
but they already have many proofs that
the evolution is there even though they
won't be long gone in 2050 we can
predict that fewer people will grow
these useless bones in their mouth if it
can keep away from feeling a lot of pain
after going to the dentist it is
orbit their real-life cyborgs technology
improves their lives and it is starting
to enhance our body - cyborgs aren't
only a part of our future they are also
part of our present and it will only get
better the world's first cyborg already
exists today a man couldn't see colors
so he asked a surgeon to implanted
device in his head now he can hear the
sound of color with an antenna that
transmits vibrations to his brain with
the device connected to bluetooth his
friends can even send him colors through
their smartphone the cyborg says that
there was no difference between a
software and his brain or his antenna
and any part of his body his technology
now that it is possible to turn a human
into a cyborg many persons will probably
want technological enhancements in the
near future - people who suffered from
injuries also replace their limbs with
robotic prosthetics more of us might be
able to do the same soon by using
technology to develop new skills what
superpower would you like to have if you
were a cyborg tell us in the comments
down below we love to hear from you the
humans of the future a scientist imagine
what humans faces would look like in a
hundred thousand years even though this
is far from now we might start seeing
differences in the following years and
it is funny to see that they look like
cartoon characters with their big head
and huge eyes the predictions were based
on what living environments could look
like in the future with the new
technologies and climate men and woman's
forehead will be bigger to accommodate a
larger brain skin will be more pigmented
and their eyelids will be thicker so
humans will be less sensible to harmful
UV radiations they will also have large
nostrils to breathe more easily and
denser hair to keep their head warm
moreover people won't only evolve to
live better but also to look better this
is why parents will choose features they
think is appealing like intense eyes
straight nose and perfect symmetry men
and women from the future could also be
enhanced by discrete technological
implants to keep their natural human
look now that we can imagine what humans
will look like in thousands of years it
would be fun to think what prehistoric
men thought we would look like don't you
think which evolution would you like to
see in 2050 we would like to hear from
you in the comments down below don't
forget to like this video and if you
want more videos like this one don't
forget to subscribe to the things thanks
for watching
[Music]